Малышка Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,, better ring, Ali, wo-o-o-o- viele Witze über Flugzeuge können wir in eine Stunde potf... Und jetzt kümmern wir uns endlich um unsere Themenwoche, Kaulkorben.
Wie viele Witze über Flugzeuge können wir in eine Stunde Podcast bringen? Seien Sie dabei beim Podcast UFO. Viel Spaß.
Und jetzt, um die Wartezeit ein bisschen zu überrücken, kommt jetzt nochmal Pachelbel, weil es so schön ist. Bis gleich.
Erst wenn ein Auto all diese Anforderungen erfüllt, dann ist es das Auto. Bitte ein Bit. Radeberger, ein Radeberger. Das Auto. Ne, das ist höher. Hey, nein, das Auto. Das Auto. Ich würde gerne mal eine Werbung... Viertel nach neun, wir sind bei Angie332, die Strassen sind voll, unsere Herzen auch mit Liebe für den neuen Song von Katie Melua. Bis gleich, wir hören uns später noch und dann kommen wir zu unserer Rubrik Das Geräusch der Woche. Bleibt dran! Wir wären eher so ein Radiosender mit sehr vielen Gadgets, so ganz vielen Geräuschen. Wir sind hier, wir sind hier, wir sind hier, wir sind hier, wir sind hier, für alle, die es auch nicht abgeschalten haben.
Wir sind tatsächlich das Podcast-Ufo und wir möchten gleich mal die Sendung beginnen mit, naja, eine Entschuldigung, trifft es vielleicht nicht ganz.
Reumütig möchten wir uns vor euch in den Dreck werfen.
Es sind Dinge geschehen in der letzten Folge, die nicht hätten passieren sollen.
Was in der letzten Woche passiert ist, bleibt in der letzten Woche.
Wir haben viele Fehler begangen, sowohl physisch als auch psychisch.
Es ging viel daneben, sowohl emotional als auch getränkehaft. Und wir möchten noch mal ganz kurz im Namen des ganzen Podcast-UFO-Teams, im Namen dieser hundert Leute der deutschen Podcast-UFO-Gemeinschaft möchten wir uns entschuldigen. Aber obwohl die Folge halt sehr polarisierend aufgenommen wurde, die einen haben gesagt, das war die beste Folge, die jemals gemacht wurde, die anderen haben uns mit Tomaten beworfen auf offener Strasse. Wir wissen selber nicht genau, wie wir damit umgehen sollen. Das ist auch so ein bisschen blödes Feedback. Also wenn ihr euch da vielleicht in Zukunft einigen könntet, wäre das... Ich rechne die Hauptschuld an diesem Desaster-Booster eingetragene Marke an, tatsächlich. Mittlerweile ist es glücklicherweise so, dass der Grossteil der Booster-Flüssigkeiten unseren Körper bereits verlassen hat, das heisst, wir können uns heute auf eine sanfte, vernünftige, ruhige Talkrunde einstellen, in der vielleicht auch mal die ein oder andere Persönlichkeit durchblitzt, aber ansonsten geht es da auch nicht weiter in die Tiefe. Ich habe tatsächlich auch ein bisschen, dass ich nicht genau weiss, was in der Folge vorkommt, weil ich sie mir nicht komplett angehört habe. Das heißt, ich weiß nicht, welche peinlichen Storys du rausgeschnitten hast. Das ist lustig. Das ist sehr gut. Das rief sich sehr gut. Ich habe zwischen, ab Folge 20 habe ich uns rausgeschnitten und habe eine alte Magnum-Folge reingeschnitten und ich habe gehofft, dass es niemand merkt. Aber es hat, glaube ich, niemand merkt. Ich habe tatsächlich mittlerweile das grosse Problem, weil ich mittlerweile mit sehr vielen Leuten kommuniziere, dass ich wirklich den Überblick darüber verliere, welche Story ich wem schon erzählt habe. Und ich manchmal in eine solche Schockstarre gerate, dass ich mit Leuten überhaupt nicht mehr reden kann, weil ich mir denke, das hat der alles schon mal gehört. Und dann kommt man natürlich, der Podcast ist dann natürlich nicht besser, weil man sowohl Storys, die man Leuten erzählt hat, von denen man weiss, dass sie den Podcast hören, nicht mehr im Podcast erzählen kann, als auch Dinge, die man schon im Podcast gesagt hat, nicht mehr den Leuten persönlich sagen kann. Deswegen ist deine Taktik sehr gut, dass du auch im Podcast Dinge einfach zweimal erzählst. Ja, genau. Oder im Podcast einfach gar nichts sage. Ja, erzähl doch heute nochmal deine Shakespeare-Geschichte, wie er zum ersten Mal ein Wort benutzt. Ey, ohne Witz. Habe ich dir wirklich letzte Folge nochmal gesagt? Ja, zum dritten Mal schon. Wirklich? Ja, beim zweiten Mal war es auch schon lustig. Aber mach's doch heute nochmal, ich freue mich da immer drüber. Wenn man was kennt, man mit mir folgen kann endlich mal, weil man die Geschichte schon zweimal gehört hat, das ist auch was Schönes. Ja, 13 Folgen sind auch einfach zu viel für mich. Ich bin gut für, sag ich mal, das erste bis vierte Date, da bin ich super, da bin ich am Limit, aber dann geht's rapide bergab, weil dann fällt mein ganzes Kartenhaus und erneut zusammen und sagt, ich hab da dieses Buch gelesen und da stehen alle deine Anekdoten eins zu eins so drin, auch die Shakespeare-Anekdote. Und dann ist natürlich ein riesiges Problem. Sehr dünnes Buch mit drei Anekdoten, die du sehr doll ausschmücken würdest und dann wäre es auch sehr schnell vorbei. Dann würdest du irgendwann einen zweiten Teil rausbringen, weil die Nachfrage sehr gross war, aber dann wären so 50, wäre es ein Plagiat von dir selber wahrscheinlich wieder. Ja genau, und das wäre die unautorisierte Version. Ich habe tatsächlich, ich habe tatsächlich als DVD, habe ich die Biografie von J.K. Rowling, aber die unautorisierte Biografie. Das heißt, da sind geschwärzte Sachen drin. Ich habe das irgendwo mal in so einem Ramschladen gefunden, wo irgendwie so DVDs verkauft wurden und überall wo unautorisiert draufsteht, muss ich es einfach haben, muss ich einfach kaufen.
Und ich natürlich als großer Harry Potter Fan, aber auch eine DVD-Box, ich kann ja mal ein Foto davon posten, DVD, die komplett gestaltet ist im Harry Potter Universum, aber darf natürlich kein einziges Symbol oder Zeichen übernehmen. Das heißt, es sind komplett wirre Löwen, irgendwelche Sachen drauf, die so halb mit Zauberei zu tun haben, aber nichts Offizielles, weil es sehr unautorisiert. Und die DVD besteht tatsächlich daraus, dass irgendwie in dem Ort, wo J.K. Rowling geboren wurde, London oder so, keine Ahnung, da irgendwie so ein Reporter-Team einfach durch die
Strassen geht und sagt, ah ja, hier neben Ihnen hat ja J.K. Rowling gewohnt, was war
das denn für eine Frau?
So, ja, nie gehört.
Besser.
Keine Ahnung, ich spreche auch kein Deutsch.
Händen Sie bitte weg und sprechen Sie mich nicht einmal an.
Ja, genau.
Als solche hochqualitativen Gespräche werden da geführt, fantastisch, eine fantastische DVD, ich glaube die zweitbeste DVD, die ich jemals gekauft habe, nach Daniel der Zauberer, der Film mit Daniel Kübelberg in der Hauptrolle. Was, der hat einen Film niemals gedreht? Ja, der hat niemals einen Film gedreht, als er am Höhepunkt seines Erfolgs war. Nie, also nie. Und da habe ich tatsächlich in einem Edeka gefunden, in einem ganz normalen Edeka-Laden, wo manchmal so DVDs verkauft werden. Das glaube ich auch, das sah immer Schätze liegen, man aber immer vorbeirennt, wenn man denkt, es sind DVDs, wir kaufen DVDs im Supermarkt, niemanden kaufen DVDs im Supermarkt. Ja, und meistens sind ja auch die DVDs die besten, die die anderen übrig lassen. Ja. Ja, und da war die DVD-Box und da war so ein wirklich so ein halben Zentimeter dicker Stapel an Preisschildern drauf, weil das immer und immer wieder überklebt wurde, weil es das Ding einfach nicht verkaufen wollte. Und das hat, glaube ich, 1,50 Euro gekostet, statt mal irgendwann 15 Euro oder so. 1,50 Euro lag es drin und hat mich angelächelt. Und ich musste es einfach haben und ich hatte noch nie so viel Spaß wie diesem Film. Das ist auch so was, wo ich das nicht ganz nachvollziehen kann, was die da machen. Also die haben halt ... Ich meine, es klingelt bei dir. Nee, bei mir hat nichts geklingelt. Hör, da ist auch ein bisschen so Geräusch, das lenkt mich ab.
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, das ist ja gut.
Was ist das denn, was klingelt da denn?
Da klingelt nichts, klingt bei dir was.
Aber das verstehe ich auch nicht wie in Supermärkten.
Passiert das auch beim Deutschlandradio, das mitten in der Moderation, und hier ist Pachel, wenn du sagst, klingt da irgendwas bei mir?
Bei mir ist das nicht irgendwas?
Du musst direkt wütender werden, du musst direkt so eine lakonische Wut die ganze Zeit mittransportieren.
Hass kriegst du aber auch, wenn du die ganze Zeit so nahe Mikrowel hast. Was ist das hier für ein Geräusch? Ja, das stimmt. Das hat eine sehr intime Geschichte, die auch schnell ins Gegenteil umschlagen kann. Nee, es ist so, warum verkaufen die das dann für 1,50 Euro? Also diese DVD hat noch nie jemand gekauft. Wenn diese DVD jemals jemand danach sucht oder die unbedingt haben will, dann kann man die auch für 9,50 Euro verkaufen. Zum Beispiel ist es ja immer so ein Zentimeterhoher Stapel von Ex-Preisschildern, die überklebt wurden. Und dann ist man irgendwann bei 50 Cent oder so. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es dadurch mehr Leute kaufen, als wenn es noch auf 9,50 Euro wäre. Ja, vor allem mit welcher Reaktion denken die Leute, die den Preis verändern, denken, die denken, okay, der Film ist immer noch scheiße, ich will ihn immer noch nicht haben, aber für das geringe Geld kann ich ihn trotzdem mitnehmen. Also macht es ja dadurch nicht interessanter. Im Gegenteil. Wir haben haben heute Folge 13, bist du abergläubisch?
Ich bin sehr abergläubisch, ja, tatsächlich.
Also wird diese Folge scheiße. Ja, ich habe auch schon meine
Kröte hier positioniert mit dem Blick auf die
Türe. Das ist interessant.
Ich lese sie jetzt gerade unter einer Leiter im Schneidersitz
und nehme jetzt eine schwarze Katze
auf deinem Schuss, ja. Am sich übergeben, warum auch immer.
Ja, genau.
Heute haben wir zwei ganz besondere Themen.
Ich glaube, ich habe vor ziemlich genau sieben Jahren einen Spiegel kaputt gemacht. Das heißt, Sie können noch live während der Folge dabei sein, wie ich endlich wieder Glück haben werde. Das war jetzt so wichtig, diese Frage. Ja, aber du hast gerade übergeleitet, die musst du dich noch reindrücken. Zum Leid. Das ist so scheiße von dir. Das ist okay, du kannst ja nochmal überleiten. Du machst die schönsten Überleitungen. Ich will, dass du das auch ein bisschen lernst und das genießen die Leute. Apropos Überleitungen. Nein, weil die Leute mögen das immer so gerne, wenn du Überleitungen machst. Genau, apropos Überleitungen. Apropos Überleitungen. Ja. Auch in Leitungen wird was transportiert, keine Ahnung. Wir reden heute jedenfalls über Licht. Was ist Licht? Was kann man mit Licht machen? Comedy-Faktor Licht, Aufregefaktor Licht, was hat Licht für eine Meinung, Skandal, Licht-Skandal, wir reden über tolle Ereignisse mit Licht aus der Vergangenheit, was ist mit Licht alles möglich, wie schnell ist Licht, wie clever ist Licht und warum brauchen wir das als Mensch. Und natürlich die Frage, darf es noch etwas mehr sein. Was? Und natürlich die Frage, darf es noch etwas mehr sein. Sehr guter Gag, danke schön. Okay, danke schön. Der war es voll wert, in meine Moderation reinzureden. Ich gebe jetzt jeden Gag bei dir in die Abnahme, dass du den einfach jemand direkt abnimmst. Ich kommentiere auch jetzt jeden Gag von dir. Aber ich finde, Licht ist deswegen so toll, weil ich bin ja ein grosser Fan von Fotografie. Also ich finde, ja Fotografie ist ja die Grösste. Bist du einer von denen, der sich jetzt in den letzten Jahren eine Spiegelreflexkamera gekauft hat, du wohnst ja in Berlin, damit da rumrennt, immer so einen kleinen Beutel bei dir hast und rumfotografiert? Ich finde, Fotografie ermöglicht es mir einfach am besten, mich irgendwie zu verwirklichen. Ich finde, wir leben heutzutage in so einer schnelllebigen, gehetzten Welt, dass es so wertvoll ist, auch mal einen Moment festzuhalten, ein kurzes innehalten, mal ein kurzes Schritt zurücknehmen. Oder einfach alle Momente festzuhalten. Nein, aber auch einfach mal aus dem Alltag einen Schritt zurücknehmen und sagen, hm, was heißt das eigentlich? Licht, Schatten, wo Licht ist, ist kein Schatten, wo Schatten ist, ist kein Licht, Salz, Pfeffer, Pfeffer, Salz. Wie ist unsere Welt aufgebaut?
Besteht sie nicht letztendlich nur aus Gegensätzen?
Sind wir nicht alle eine Ansammlung von verschiedenen Polen, die in uns kämpfen?
Bestehen wir nicht alle... Sind wir nicht der Schatten, den wir auf den Weg vor uns werfen?
Richtig.
Sind wir nicht der Schatten, den wir auf den Weg eines Mädchens, was vor uns geht, werfen?
Und wo kommen wir hin, wenn wir nur diesem Schatten folgen, wenn wir immer nur unserem eigenen Schatten folgen? Sollten wir nicht ins Licht schauen, sollten wir uns nicht umdrehen, dem Licht ins Auge sehen und sagen, das ist eine sehr enttäuschende Sonnenfinsternis, das ist das Enttäuschendste, was ich in meinem Leben je gesehen habe. Das ist so scheiße und meine Augen brennen wie Kacke. Meine Augen brennen wie die Hölle. Ich habe extra den Ratgeber noch im Geolino gesehen, wo es heißt, lassen Sie Ihre Kinder in die Sonne schauen und schauen Sie sich die Sonne in den Reflektionen Ihrer Kinderaugen an.
Die Kinder waren wahnsinnig glücklich, ich habe kaum was gesehen. Ja, war furchtbar. Aber war das wirklich, also jetzt mal ganz kurz zum Thema Licht, also da finde ich... Ich fand das so lustig, ich fand das so lustig, ich hab den ganzen Tag davor, hab ich gehört, wie teuer, wie sunthaft teuer diese Brillen waren, mit denen man da reingucken kann, dass sie überall ausverkauft waren, dass man überall sind Tipps, wie man sich was selber bauen kann, alle waren genervt schon, weil sie diese Brillen nicht bekommen haben und sich jetzt irgendwie mit Kräpppapier was Neues bauen müssen. Und dann ist man an dem Tag und man sieht nichts, weil der Himmel wolkig ist. Ja, und wie viele Milliarden überhaupt dafür ausgegeben wurden, dass die Sonnenfinsternis überhaupt stattfinden kann. Die ganzen Leute, die auf der Erde rumlaufen, die NASA, die da Sachen hochschicken und so, das hat ja mehr Jahre gekostet. Die NASA, die vor allem den Mond verschiebt, damit die Sonnenfinsternis stattfinden kann überhaupt. Aber saßt du auch den ganzen Tag zu Hause und hast dir einen Tweet überlegt und dir ist nichts eingefallen? Ja, so geht's mir jeden Tag. Das ist eigentlich sinnbildlich für jeden Tag. Und deswegen jetzt mal an alle Humorfreaks da draußen, am Sonntag ist Zeitumstellung. Das heißt, wenn ihr diese Folge jetzt am Samstag hört oder wann auch immer, dann habt ihr jetzt noch die Gelegenheit, euch jetzt hinzusetzen, euch einen coolen Tweet zu überlegen. Schickt uns eure besten Zeitumstellungstweets. Ich habe tatsächlich schon einen in der Pipeline, aber ich will natürlich, dass ihr mitmacht mit dem Hashtag, warte, jetzt braucht man einen guten Gag, Vielleicht, dass man das Wort Zeitumstellung umstellt, weil es ja eine Umstellung ist, so umtzeitstellung. Manchmal muss ich auch einen Schritt zurück, kennst du das, wenn du zum Beispiel mit jemandem ein Gespräch führst gerade und in deinem Kopf nimmst du dein inneres Ich so einen Schritt zurück und guckt auf die Person, die gerade spricht und denkt sich so, mhm, mhm, mhm, ja, du, die letzten acht bis sieben Sätze haben überhaupt gar keinen Sinn ergeben. Und man schaut nur noch tatenlos dabei zu, wie man irgendeinen Schwachsinn erzählt und kommt gar nicht mehr rein. Und man geht noch einen Schritt zurück mit dem Ich, weil man sieht, weil man denkt, man muss das Kunstwerk von ein bisschen weiter weg betrachten. Was ist das eigentlich für eine Frisur? Und wie sieht daswerk von ein bisschen weiter weg betrachten. Ja, das stimmt. Was ist das eigentlich für eine Frisur? Wie sieht es schon wieder aus, mein Gott? Mit wem redest du überhaupt? Aber mir fällt tatsächlich manchmal auf. Weißt du, was mir gerade aufgefallen ist? Gute Überleitung. Ich glaube, wenn man mit dir telefoniert, kann man den Hörer weglegen, zehn Minuten lang. Und du würdest noch reden, wenn man den aufnehmen würde. Das stimmt, ja, das stimmt. Das ist richtig. Aber also also, bist du jemanden, wenn man mit dir telefoniert oder mit dir einen Podcast macht und man erzählt zehn Minuten lang was, reagierst du dann irgendwie? Also so ein, ja, ja, ja, ja. Oder so gar nichts, oder machst du Stille? Nee, ich versuche immer reinzureden. Ja, bei jeder Gelegenheit. In jeder Gelegenheit. In deine Atempausen, ich rechne mir mit so einem Geodreieck und einem Taschenrechner und ich habe mittlerweile Statistiken geführt, wann du atmest zwischen Wörtern, wann ich statistisch gesehen am besten einsteigen könnte, um mit einem neuen Gag, mit einem neuen Thema, mit einer Wahnsinnsüberleitung, mit einer Anmoderation. Okay, das ist krass. Mir ist letztens aufgefallen tatsächlich, dass es nicht genug Gags gibt auf der Welt. Es gibt einfach nicht genug Gags. Es gibt auch nicht genug Akkorde, deswegen ist Sonita Bohlen völlig zu Unrecht in der Kritik. Und es ist genau mit Gags das Gleiche, es ist mit Kunst. Du hast eine begrenzte Anzahl von Möglichkeiten, du hast nur 26 Buchstaben, du hast ein paar Sonderzeichen, gut, du hast Caps Lock und so, du kannst ein bisschen variieren, du hast auch Regieanweisungen zu machen, du kannst neue Spielmittel ausprobieren, aber da bin ich voll bei deiner Meinung, es gibt irgendwann Grenzen, die du erreichst.
Und jetzt singen wir einen Song darüber, über die Grenzen von Gags. Ich hab mal ein bisschen Gag gemacht. Oder ich habe mir letztens überlegt, also zum Beispiel, es gibt ja gewisse Standardsituationen, in denen man sich wiederfindet.
Und wir sind ja lustige Leute, ja, wir sind ja Humboldt zu zieren.
Und wir versuchen natürlich auch aus den Standardsituationen das Bestmögliche rauszuholen und die lustig zu machen. Zum Beispiel, wie müsste man sich eine Geburtstagseinladung von einem Stefan Teizzi ausdenken? Da bleibt kein Auge trocken. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass ich mir die Geburtstagseinladung durchlesen kann, ohne bei der Hälfte abbrechen zu müssen und zu sagen, das ist aber ein lustiger Typ. Ich beende auch jede Geburtstagseinladung mit dem Wort, bringt doch gute Laune mit, um für Verpflegung zu sorgen. Ich habe kaum noch welche, ja. Für Verpflegung ist gesorgt, Zwinker-Smiley. Genau, jeder muss seine gute Laune selbst mitbringen, Zwinker. Das ist übrigens auch geil, dass mittlerweile bei handgeschriebenen Karten der Zwinker-Smiley auch auf der Seite liegt. Auf der Seite stimmt. Das würde ich aber auch machen, ja. Das ist völlig dämlich, weil natürlich kann man das richtig malen dann. Und es ist ja nur, dass seine Not liegt ja auf der Seite, wenn man digital schreibt. Aber warum hat sich das so durchgesetzt? Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, weil es tatsächlich eher erkannt wird als ein richtiger Smiley. Ich glaube, ich würde so einen Zwinker-Smiley gar nicht verstehen, weil auch, sag ich mal, relativ Realitätsfan ist. Was ich tatsächlich machen würde, glaube ich, als Gag, den wahrscheinlich niemand verstehen würde, ich würde, wenn ich eine Geburtstagseinladung schreiben würde, ich würde gewisse Grußkarten-Konventionen mischen. Also zum Beispiel, ja, hey, Leute, kommt zu meiner Schaumparty, cool und liebe Grüße von der kleinen Clara und dann so eine kleine Babyhand, die mir in so eine pinke Farbe noch so auf den Brief gedrückt hat. Verstehst du, so zwei Welten mischen, Geburtstagsgrüße und wir haben ein Kind und Hochzeitsfoto, genau, ja. Und bitte seht nicht schöner aus als die Braut, wo das nicht möglich ist. Es gibt ja auch traurige Standard-Situationen, wo man vielleicht nicht mit einem Gag umbringt.
Guten Flug zum Beispiel.
Zum Beispiel, das ist wirklich sehr verwerflich, was du da gerade mal, das will ich mich dafür distanzieren, zum Beispiel Beerdigung. Kannst du eine Einladung zu einer Beerdigung, wie lustig kann man da sein? Ja, gut, da wir noch keine... Auf einer Skala von 1 bis 5 Mockriff. Ich wollte gerade sagen, da wir noch keine allgegenwärtige Comedy-Skala eingeführt haben, ist es schwer zu sagen. Aber weißt du, was saulustig wäre? Weißt du, was lustig ist, was wirklich, kurz nochmal, diese Woche, wir können das nicht ganz verschweigen. Du kannst nicht, du hast mich jetzt zweimal schon damit unterbrochen und hast exakt dasselbe gesagt wie wir. Ich habe gesagt, oh was lustig wäre und du, ey weißt du was lustig wäre? Wir sind beim Thema, es gibt keinen Grund mich zu unterbrechen, wir sind schon beim Thema Dinge, die lustig sind. Du bist vollkommen richtig, du bist goldrichtig. Setz dich mal
hin, genieß die Sonne, setz dich ins Licht,
du bist im Spotlight, du bist schon da.
Ich warte schon seit neun
Tagen jetzt auf die nächste Sonnenfinsternis
und ich sitze die ganze Zeit
vom Fenster und es kommt nichts. Genau, ich schreiche
jeden Tag wieder Kreuze in meinem Kalender ab,
dann kommt endlich die nächste Sonnenfinsternis.
Aber weißt du, was so lustig wäre, wenn man bei der Beerdigung, während sein Sarg runtergefahren wird, die Tetris-Melodie spielt. So, und ja, ich weiß, ich war vor einer Woche auf einer Nightwash-Aufzeichnung mit Luke Mockridge, ich kenne alle Luke-Mockridge-Gags auswendig, und das war einer davon. Wie sieht der, hast du ihn angefasst, wie sieht der aus? Nein, also ich finde tatsächlich, Luke Mockridge macht da seinen Job in dieser moderativen Nightwatch-Geschichte sehr gut.
Da muss ich ganz kurz unterbrechen.
Genau, apropos lustig.
Was wirklich lustig war diese Woche, als einzige Sache, die diese Woche lustig war, war eben die Pressemitteilung, dass aufgrund der aktuellen Ereignisse die Sendung von Luke Mockridge ausfällt. Weil, mit Zitat, es ist eine Woche, in der man nicht lachen sollte. Und deswegen wird … In der Woche ist kein Platz für Comedy, und deswegen fällt Luke Mockridge aus. Meine Antwort war, das ist falsch, in dieser Woche gehört keine Comedy, also sendet Doppelfolgen von Luke Mockridge. Aber wahrscheinlich einfach, weil Luke Mockridge's Song zu abgehoben ist. Er hat gesagt, ich kann mich nicht lustig auf diese Woche, kann diese Woche nicht lustig Revue passieren lassen. Aber schade, dass es in anderen Wochen auch nicht schafft. Ich meine, ich finde, so eine Luke-Mockert-Show vergeht immer wie im Flug, von daher ist das auch nicht so wild. So, ja, worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, zum Beispiel bei Twitter, ja, ich bin ja ein Twitter-Maestro, ja. Ich finde es auch sehr gut, dass wir uns thematisch nicht im Kreis bringen. Nein, der Kreis entsteht dadurch, dass ich gerade, ich mache einen Anlauf, du schubst mich irgendwo zu einer anderen Seite und ich laufe einmal im Kreis, um meinen Weg letztlich wieder fortsetzen zu können. Zum Beispiel Situationen, in denen ich gemerkt habe, dass es zu wenig Gags gibt. Angenommen, man möchte jetzt zum Beispiel einen anderen Twitterer empfehlen, seinen Twitter-Follower, ja, so klassisch Follower Friday, dann kann man zwei Dinge machen. Entweder man schreibt folgt ad Stephan Tizze oder wenn man lustig ist, schreibt man folgt auf gar keinen Fall ad Stephan Tizze. Meine Frage, ist das Comedy-Potential da schon ausgeschöpft? Und ich glaube, ja. Ich glaube, aber was kann man da noch machen? Viele verwechseln das Gegenteil zu sagen mit Ironie. Aha! Nur wenn man ein Gegenteil sagt von etwas, was man, also wenn jemand fragt, ja, wie geht's dir eigentlich? Ja, schlecht, es ist nicht lustig. Und dann sagt man, Spaß beiseite, nein, es ist nicht lustig. Also nur das Gegenteil zu sagen, ist noch keine Comedy Opportunity voll ausgenutzt. Danke, Stefan, aus.
Ich habe jetzt Mike gedroppt. Moment mal, Moment mal, ich finde, also wir sind ja hier im Bereich der L-Form, wir brechen die Erwartungen.
Damit, dass jemand auf Twitter schreibt, folgt Punkt, Punkt, Punkt auf gar keinen Fall, damit rechnest du erstmal nicht.
Du hast die Form gebrochen, das Schema gebrochen, die Erwartungen enttäuscht und damit entsteht ein humoristischer Reiz, der umgesetzt wird durch ein Lachen, ein schnelles Ein- und Ausatmen, Zwerchfeld ist involviert, von daher können wir hier schon im weitesten Sinne von humoristischem Potential reden. Da bin ich völlig auf der Gegenseite von dir. Die Frage ist nur... Alles ist lustiger, wenn man auf einem Segway sitzt. Ja, das stimmt. Oh, ui. Mir sind drei Gags gleichzeitig angefallen, die alle drei katastrophal schlecht waren. Und haben sich in deinem Kopf Luft aufgelöst. Ja, haben sich gegenseitig einfach aufgefressen. Komm, die Kernschmelze im Kopf von Florian Diebe. Ich bin einfach so ein QuantitätsJoker. Mir fällt wahnsinnig viel ein, aber nichts davon ist wirklich gut.
Aber zum Beispiel, also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel irgendeinen Twitter-Menschen, muss jetzt blauer Haken oder nicht, sagen wir mal gut, er hat einen blauen Haken, sagen wir mal.
Das tut nicht zur Sache, aber du wolltest mal wieder deinen blauen Haken aufmerksam machen.
Nee, das hat in der Sache gar nichts zu tun.
Aber sagen wir jetzt einfach mal, Ed Pommes Ruppel, Florian Witt, bekannter Comedian-Mator aus dem Fernsehen, Wow-Comedian, ja, mittlerweile auch in der, einfach gab es einen schlechteren Zeitpunkt, als im fucking Flughafen-Magazin aufzutauchen für Florentin Will. Da bin ich mal in einem fucking Flughafen-Magazin, die Flughafen-Presse interviewt mich und dann, 20 Minuten später die grosse Tragödie, alle haben keinen Bock mehr auf Flugzeuge in Flughäfen. Alter, Alter, wenn das kein fucking Scheiss-Timing ist. Der grösste Knick in meiner Karriere. Ich glaube, wir sollten diesen Podcasts in den letzten zwei Jahren veröffentlicht. Genau, losfliegen lassen. Das ist noch nicht, es ist noch zu früh. Not ready for take-off. Du warst noch nicht fertig mit deiner Anäkdote, oder? Nein, ich wollte, ich wollte, nein, ich wollte dich fragen, wie man das denn lustig umsetzen kann. Also wenn du, angenommen, du würdest jetzt heute Abend, sagen wir mal, du würdest nach der Aufzeichnung jetzt einen Tweet tweeten, zu sagen, hey, folgt, folgt, zum Beispiel, hey, folgt Ed Florentin Will, wie würdest du es humoristisch umsetzen, wie würdest du dich dieser Herausforderung stellen, würdest du sagen, es ist ein Spiel aus Licht und Schatten, es ist ein Mix, irgendwie bring ich Struktur rein, beleuchte ich nur von links oder wie mache ich es? Ich würde erstmal so eine ganz dramatische Stimmung aufbauen, indem man sagt, Leute, hier auf Twitter geht ja schon, sind wir ganz ehrlich, fassen wir uns mal alle an kurz. Stellen wir uns mal ganz kurz alle in einen Kreis, alle mal ganz kurz herkommen. Komm mal ganz kurz her, du komm mal ganz kurz, leg mal ganz kurz den Stift weg, ja mal kurz den Stift weg, mal alle Laptops zu, mal bitte alle Laptops zu gerade. Leute, ganz kurz mal eben, ganz kurz, komm mal eben, alle bitte, Nina, komm mal bitte auch da weg jetzt gerade, alle bitte, komm, nicht anfassen die Hartplatte. Ganz kurz nur, ganz kurz. Es ist ja alle nicht mehr das Wahre hier, es ist echt, seit ein paar Jahren geht es bergab mit uns und deswegen ganz kurz wollte ich euch nur sagen, folgt Pommesruppel. Und Leute würden aufstehen und applaudieren. Ja, finde ich gut. Licht. Gut, also dann kann ich mich da drauf verlassen, dass das passiert. Nee, weißt du, ich finde Licht, also gerade, ich finde Licht ist das schönste Geschenk, das wir Menschen haben. Ich wollte ganz kurz mal erklären, was Licht ist überhaupt, damit wir wissen, woher es kommt und wohin es geht. Steigen wir mal, ja gut, dann gehen wir in Medias Res, steigen wir doch direkt ins Thema ein. Was ist Licht eigentlich? Also Licht ist, sind elektromagnetische Wellen in einer gewissen Frequenz, sodass wir die sehen können. Je nachdem, wie schnell diese Frequenz ist, sind andere Farben für uns zu sehen. Gegenstände, die wir sehen, brechen das Licht. Ich denke, das reicht erstmal. Wir haben eine gute Übersicht, damit gewonnen wir uns anfangen. Florentin? Aber was ist denn eine Farbe? Verschiedene Wellenlängen von Licht. Farben sind verschiedene Wellenlängen von Licht. Aber was ist denn dann Gott? Genau, und darf es noch etwas mehr sein. Und was wollt ihr dann? Aber ich finde, du hast da einen echt guten Punkt angesprochen mit den Farben, weil ich finde, die Welt hat so viele verschiedene Farben und eigentlich ist es nur in der Fotografie wirklich möglich, diese Farben wirklich einzufangen, weil jeder Moment hat seine eigene Farbe, jeder Moment hat seine eigene Atmosphäre. Es sind ja so viele Momente jeden Tag, man verliert ja den Überblick. Und das Schönste ist, an allen verschiedenen Momenten, sie können gleich aussehen mit dem gleichen Instagram-Filter. Ja, genau, natürlich sehen alle genauso aus wie die Momente von anderen Leuten. Aber weißt du, also ich möchte mal eine kurze Metapher anbringen fürs Leben, ja, weil wir haben ja in unserem Leben viel mit Bildern zu tun. Wir denken ja viel in Bildern, man denkt, was sehe ich aus? Sehe ich aus wie irgendein Topmodel?
Also entspreche ich dem Bild eines Mannes, entspreche ich dem Bild einer Frau? Hast du dich jemals gefragt, ob du aussiesst wie ein Topmodel? Ja, habe ich relativ schnell mit Nein beantwortet, damit hat sich das erledigt und ich habe weiter Erdnussbutter und Apfel gegessen, das war's. Aber nein, ich möchte auch mal ein ernstes Thema anreissen. Bild heisst ja nicht nur Fotografie, sondern Bild ist ja eine Gesamtkonstante, die sich durch unser Leben zieht. Das Bild, was heisst es eigentlich, Mann zu sein, was heisst es, Frau zu sein, was für ein, passe ich in das Bild eines Schülers, eines Lehrers? Bist du gerade auf so einem Selbstfindungstrip oder so? Du bist so nachdenklich heute. Ich bin tatsächlich ein bisschen nachdenklich, ja, ich mache mir viel Gedanken über Bilder. Und ich finde, manchmal kann man auch das falsche Bild vor Augen haben.
Du kennst es, man hat Bilder von Idolen, von Vorbildern, man hat Träume, Wünsche. Wenn man sich dann die Zukunft vorstellt, hat man oft einfach ein konkretes Bild vor Augen, zum Beispiel eine grosse Wohnung, eine schöne Frau, eine nette Familie. Das sind alles Bilder, die sich durch dein Alles klar. Aber warum denken wir nicht auch mal mehr in Gerüchen?
Nee, denk mal in Bilder. Wir denken mal kurz in Bilder.
Ich gebe dir ein Wort und du sagst mir das erste Bild, was dir dazu einfällt.
Ja, wie soll ich dir das sagen?
Lampe.
Ja, da kann ich jetzt auch nur ein Wort sagen.
Beschreib halt, du musst es schnell beschreiben, Assoziation.
Flasche.
Flasche liegt in meinem Flur, liegt eine Pfandflasche.
Boah, ich bin unfassbar kreativ. Nasenspray. Nasenspray. Ein Einhorn, auf dem ein Pfau reitet in den Sonnenuntergang. Keks. Lecker. Einfach schwarz, dein Kopf ist schwarz und in Weiss steht in Comic Sans lecker. Nein, aber ich möchte auch mal ganz kurz noch auf die Sachen mit dem Bildern zu kommen. Manchmal hat man das Bild seines Traums so nah vor Augen, dass man die Realität vielleicht gar nicht mehr sieht. Man hat dieses Bild, das man schon so lange gemalt hat, von dieser perfekten Zukunft, hält man vor seinem Gesicht, aber es ist auch wie ein Schutzschild, man lässt nichts an sich ran, man lässt die Realität nicht an sich ran und das wahre Leben zieht in einem vorbei. Und man kann die Realität auch gar nicht mehr sehen wirklich. Und vielleicht läuft man auch dem falschen Bild hinterher. Ich meine, du kennst es vielleicht, du hast vielleicht mal Super Mario Kart auf dem N64 gespielt mit den vier kleinen Bildschirmen. Und vielleicht spielst du dein ganzes Spiel und guckst auf den falschen Bildschirmen und denkst, Alter, ich bin Erster, wie geil. Und am Ende des Spiels guckst du auf deinen Eingang und bist die ganze Zeit gegen die Wand gefahren. So kann dein Leben ... Das hat mir da schon drei, vier Mal passiert. Nacheinander. Und was ist, wenn du dein Leben genauso führst? Wenn du eigentlich auf den Bildschirm eines anderen schaust, die Vorstellungen und Träume von anderen Menschen lebst und gar nicht deine eigenen. Und selbst fährst du den ganzen Tag nur gegen die Wand, denkst aber, du würdest dem richtigen Ziel hinterherlaufen und vielleicht tust du das gar nicht. Ui, das war ganz schön gut jetzt. Das war wirklich mal das Beste, was ich seit langem, seit zehn Minuten gehört habe. Dankeschön. Und deswegen finde ich, ist Fotografie einfach so eine schöne Kunst, weil es die einfach lehrt, mit solchen Bildern umzugehen. Was sind Bilder eigentlich? Deswegen ist Fotografie so schön, weil es nichts mit dem eben Gesagten zu tun hat. Bilder sind Phantome, sage ich oft. Bilder sind wie Geister. Sie entstehen, aber sie verschwinden wieder. Sie entstehen im Kopf, sie entstehen in der Realität. Ich finde das Interessante, wie schnell Licht einfach ist. Licht ist unfassbar schnell. Wie schnell genau, Florentin? Sehr schnell. So sieben Mal um die Erde in einer Sekunde oder sowas? Keine Ahnung, sowas in der Richtung. Irgendwas mit drei, dreihundert Meter, daununderttausend Meter pro Sekunde. Das heißt, man sieht Dinge immer schon, bevor sie passieren. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Das ist falsch. Das ist falsch. Man sieht Dinge nach. Nimm es nochmal zurück, geh nochmal einen Schritt zurück. Geh nochmal einen Schritt zurück und denk nochmal zurück. Und schau mich nochmal in einem anderen Licht an. Auch interessant. Nee, aber ich finde es echt interessant, wie schnell Licht ist. Und das ist ja das Tollste, was Einstein immer rausgefunden hat, finde ich, dass nicht so schnell ist wie Licht. Licht ist dir immer einen Schritt voraus. Oh, das ist ein schöner Punkt eigentlich. Dein Bild, was du ausstrahlst, ist immer bei den Leuten schon, kommt es an, bevor du selbst ankommst. Bevor du selber gecheckst, dass du dann da bist. Oder bevor du überhaupt da bist. Die Leute sehen dich, bevor du sie siehst. Das ist auch sehr peinlich, wenn man sehr weit aufeinander zuläuft mit Bekannten, man weiß nicht genau, man hat sich schon gegrüsst von weitem weg. Und wie reagiert man dann, wie geht man die letzten 50 Meter auf denjenigen zu? Man weiß es nicht. Aber das ist tatsächlich auch so ein Punkt, wo es einfach kein soziales Protokoll gibt, weil man kann der Person nicht die ganze Zeit in die A-, aber alles andere als die Person anzuschauen ist ganz klar Vermeidung von Augenkontakt. Das ist übrigens mein Lebenswerk, ein soziales Protokoll aufzuschreiben, wie man in solchen Situationen, wie man in allen Situationen reagieren sollte.
Es ist eine Million Seiten lang, es ist sehr dick, es ist ein riesen Wälzer und damit man das in der Tasche mittragen kann, ist es so ganz klein, ein ganz kleines Buch, was man mit einer Lupe nur lesen kann. Ich hatte mal die Idee, dass man einen Kurzfilm macht, der nur aus so einer Situation besteht. Der anfängt damit, dass sich zwei Leute aufeinander zulaufen und dann in diesen Blicken, nur mit Blicken eine ganze Geschichte zu erzählen, ich denke da so an 90 bis 120 Minuten, dass man nur mit den Blicken eine ganze Geschichte erzählt. Kurzfilm, tollereinander, es ist ein GIF, es ist ein GIF, es ist ein vier Bilder GIF und am Ende laufen sie aneinander vorbei und dann ist die Geschichte vorbei, aber die Geschichte ist schon passiert.
Manchmal hat man ja komplett abgeschlossene Geschichten mit Menschen, manchmal sitzt man in der U-Bahn jemandem gegenüber und schaut sie nur an und hat eigentlich eine komplette Geschichte, man lernt sich kennen, man macht das, macht dies und dann kommt die grosse Trennung und hier und dann ist die Geschichte abgeschlossen, man verlässt sich wieder, man hat alles zusammen erlebt, was das Leben hergibt. Ich gucke keinem mehr in die Augen in der U-Bahn, seitdem ich einmal angemacht wurde. Ist vielleicht klüger, manche Geschichten sind auch nicht so ideal, es ist richtig. Aber Comedy-Faktor Licht, ganz kurz, Lasertag. Hast du mal Lasertag gespielt? Nein, tatsächlich. Ein Spiel, was nur auf Licht beruht. Aber sind wir jetzt tatsächlich, Laser ist jetzt gleich wie Licht oder was? Wollen wir uns nicht Laser für eine andere Rolle aufheben? Laser ist gebündeltes Licht. Okay, wenn du das sagst, du hast vorhin Einstein erwähnt, deswegen glaube ich dir jetzt mal. Das ist auch mein Trick, wenn ich mal abends weg bin und Leute beeindrucken will, einfach nur sehr viele Namen droppen, die Einstein, Kleinstein … Wie viele Physiker kennst du denn, wie viele Physiker kennen wir denn?
Ich kenne Einstein, ich kenne Kepler, ich kenne …
Newton?
Faraday, ich kenne Newton, Heisenberg, Max Planck, ich kenne Schopenhauer. Heidegger. Und Goebbels. Schweinsteiger. Wolwig. Aha. Crow. Und Pauli. Beisen. Und Emser. Donnerstag. Und Logitech. Mhm, 44. Donnerstag. Hatten wir schon, Entschuldigung. Den hatten wir schon. Ja, gut, Physiker kenne ich jetzt nicht so viele. Ist okay, ist nicht so wild. Aber vielleicht kann man den Namen erfinden, man weiss ja nicht unbedingt, der andere weiss ja nicht unbedingt. Aber wo kommt das Licht her? Also wo hat es angefangen? Energiefällen. Nein, ja gut, aber wo davor, wo kommt es denn her? Ich glaube, Licht kommt ungefähr, durch Licht kommt ungefähr daher, wo auch Einhörner und Magnete herkommen. Ja, das ist ungefähr, das ist für mich in einer Schublade. Die Herkunft von Magneten und Licht ist ungefähr die Lenkschublade. Das sind beides Dinge, die ich mir nicht erklären kann. Und das sind auch so Dinge, wo ich auch beschlossen habe, dass ich das niemals herausfinden werde, weil, ähm, das sind halt, also man weiß ja nicht, das verschwindet halt nie, Licht verschwindet halt nie, gefühlt. Also Licht muss ja erstickt werden. Da kannst du Licht auch ausmachen. Ja, genau. Aber ist doch schon verrückt, dass wir Menschen, wir sind auf diese Erde gekommen und haben die Sonne gesehen und haben gesagt, Alter, sowas brauchen wir auch und haben es halt einfach geschafft. Haben es geschafft, Lampen zu bauen und haben einfach eine Sonne selber gebaut. Die Menschen bauen alles nach, wenn sie sehen, wenn sie was sehen, können die es auch nachbauen. Naja, du kannst keine Wolke bauen. Doch. Na, eine Wolke kannst du nicht so einfach bauen. Du kannst kein Gelände erzeugen aus dem Wasser. In diesem, doch, in diesem, hier, Hitler. Ja. Unser alter Freund Hitler. Herr Hitler, Bungee Hitler. Bungee Hitler hat damals auch, er wollte auch diese Riesenkuppel bauen, weißt du? Ja. Welthauptstadt Germania, Riesenprojekte, wollte eine Riesenkuppel bauen, wo 300.000 Menschen in dieser Halle sitzen können, bei einer überkuppelten Halle. Für sein Stand-Up-Programm, ja. Das wäre für seine Impro-Comedy-Gruppe mit Gervilson Himmler, die Poetry. Und das da drin, das wäre so groß geworden, es wurde ja nicht fertig gebaut, dass da Wolken drin gewesen wären. Da wäre ein eigenes Wetter drin gewesen. What? Von der Kondensation von 300.000 Menschen, ja. Das heißt, wenn das so gewesen wäre, hätte man wahrscheinlich auch, kann man auch wahrscheinlich im Labor einfach Wolken. Aber ist das nicht ein bisschen ekelhaft, deine eigenen Ausdünstungen regnen dann wieder auf dich runter? Ja, es ist ekelhaft, aber es ist auch ein bisschen sexy. Ist auch ein bisschen geil eigentlich, stimmt. Ja, eigentlich ein bisschen geil. Man weiss ja immer nicht, wessen Schweiß man abkriegt.
Eigentlich gut. Eigentlich ist das eine gute Idee.
Ich glaube, Hitler wäre eine super Comedy-Figur.
Ohne Witz.
Ja, aber ich frage mich, wo kommt das Licht her?
Also wo ist es entstanden? Wo waren die ersten Lichtstrahlen? Es ist also, viele sagen ja, es war Gott.
Relativ viele sagen, nope.
Gott sprach, es werde Licht. Ja, auf dieses Zitat wollte ich hin, weil ich habe mir ein paar Zitate rausgeschrieben zum Thema Licht. Okay, Fun Facts, Licht Fun Facts. Hat geschrieben, Gott sprach, es werde Licht am dritten Tag und damit gab es Licht. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass die Bibel ist nicht geil geschrieben am Anfang. Nee. Das machen wir, das gucken wir jetzt mal nach.
Die Anfangsteile der Bibel, man denkt ja, wow, hat es sich ja auch verkauft, ist ein Bestseller. Ja, aber du brauchst natürlich einen Eyecatcher, wenn die besten Teile erst auf Seite 1200 kommen, dann ist es natürlich schwierig. Ja, aber es ist nicht geil geschrieben am Anfang, es ist halt wirklich nicht gut geschrieben, der Autor war ein Idiot. Idiot. Ja. Der Idiot.
Also, am Anfang schuf Gott Himmel und Erde, und die Erde war wüst und leer, und es war
finster auf der Tiefe, und der Geist Gottes schwebte auf dem Wasser. Okay, gutes Bild, bleibe ich dabei. Und Gott sprach, es werde Licht, und es ward Licht. Ja, ein bisschen wiederholt. Und Gott sah, dass das Licht gut war. Da schied Gott das Licht von der Finsternis und nannte das Licht Tag und die Finsternis Nacht, da ward aus Abend und morgen der erste Tag, und Gott sprach, es werde eine Feste zwischen den Wassern, und die sei ein Unterschied zwischen den Wassern. Da machte Gott die Feste und schied das Wasser unter der Feste von dem Wasser über die Feste und das... Ist halt nicht gut. Ist halt eigentlich... Und da war das Fest und die Feste und das Wasser, aber die Feste und dem Wasser der Feste und es geschah also. Und Gott nannte die Feste Himmel. Aber wo kam dann Noah? Und vor allem ist Gott der Vater. Ja, und der Sohn, und der Heilige Geist. Aber das ist kein neues Thema. Ich glaube, damit hauen wir jetzt niemanden vom Hock an. Wir haben jetzt diese Erkenntnis, hast du diese neue Serie, Kimi Schmidt, auf Netflix gesehen? Nein, noch nicht, obwohl ich großer Fan von ... Eine Stelle muss ich spoilern, von Tina Faber zu, wolltest du sagen. Nein. Warte, die hat auch bei The Office mitgespielt, Aaron, warte, red erst mal
weiter, Ellie Kemper, Ellie Kemper, okay,
verfolgt. Gut, dankeschön,
und da ist jedenfalls eine Gerichtsszene,
und ein Verteidiger
verteidigt sich selber und ist ein
Reverend, ein Gläubiger, und
er sagt dann, dass
der heilige Geist sein Verteidiger
ist und deutet dann auf den
leeren Stuhl neben ihm, das ist eine sehr lustige Geschichte. Man muss wohl dabei gewesen sein. Man muss wahrscheinlich dabei gewesen sein. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Ich finde ja Noah, wo wir gerade bei Bibel sind, Noah ist eine absolute Lieblingsstory, finde ich so geil, finde ich so verrückt, vor allem, also ich meine, du kennst es ja aus der Schule, Bestrafungen sind ja immer so eine schwierige Frage und damit haben sich natürlich auch die Leute aus der Bibel beschäftigt, weil es gibt oft Bestrafungen, die einfach unfair sind und Bestrafungen, die auch nicht jeden gleich treffen. Also wenn du dir das mal so eine Klasse vorstellst und der Lehrer sagt, so, als Strafe macht jetzt jeder Aufgabe eins bis vier noch zusätzlich zu Hause, dann denken sie sich manchmal, ja gut, keinen Stress mache ich ohne weiteres. und natürlich die absoluten Mathe-Loser trifft es natürlich sehr hart, damit ist es sehr unfair. Und so was ähnliches passiert in der Bibel auch, und zwar, weil die Menschen scheiße sind, beschließt Gott, ich bestrafe die ganze Erde, die gesamte Existenz, alles, was ich erschaffen habe, werde ich bestrafen, und zwar, ich lasse es 40 Tage lang und 40 Nächte lang regnen. Ich denke mir, als die Botschaft auf der Erde angekommen ist, müssen doch echt die Fische gesagt haben, yes, yes, nice one, yes. Weil ich meine, das ist schon natürlich klar, natürlich kann Gott sich nicht um alle kümmern und ich meine, wahrscheinlich würde uns auch keine Bestrafung einfallen, die alle gleich hart trifft, aber da muss ich sagen, da haben die Fische wahrscheinlich schon sich gedacht, da will ich jetzt gut raus. Habe ich schon ganz gut gemacht. Das stimmt. Boah, harte, harte Strafe, Gott, Mensch, ziemlich hart, boah, was sagst du, Al? Ja, krass, ziemlich radikale Strafe, oder? Hui, aber nochmal, hui, und alle Vögel waren richtig angepasst. So viel an die Vögel, Alter, willst du mich verarschen, Regen, Alter, wir haben kein Haus, wir können kein Dach bauen, wir sind Vögel, wir bauen so ein Nest, wir sitzen da in den ganzen Agromen, wir haben kein Dach. Und dann waren da die Möwen, Und die Möwen auch so, yes, ich kann sowohl schwimmen als auch fliegen, bitches, yeah. Und die Enten auch. Die Enten dachten sich, wie geil ist das denn? What the fuck? Water of a duck's back, glaube ich, die Ente war da tatsächlich auch ganz gut dabei. Und dann gibt es ja noch diese Insekten, die auf Wasser gehen können. Ja, kleiner Funfact am Rande. Dankeschön.
Bibel hat auch viel Komiteil Potenzial. Möchtest du noch mal die Geschichte raushauen, wie am Ende, wie lustig es wäre, wenn er am Ende stehen würde? Nein, der Ge... Nein, will ich nicht. Hör mal auf jetzt! Ja, Entschuldigung! Ich habe tatsächlich mal versucht auszurechnen, wann... Wann die Erde untergeht. Ne, wann Noah war. Weil Noah hat ja seine Frau mitgenommen und seine Kinder, und das ist relativ gut dokumentiert, also man weiß, wie viele Kinder er hatte. Und dann sind wir halt im neuen Land irgendwie und sagen dann, okay, cool, alle anderen Menschen sind tot, fangen wir an, wir müssen eine neue Bevölkerung aufbauen. Und du hast ja nicht mehr nur eine gewisse Kapazität an Fruchtbarkeit, die du übertragen kannst. Das heisst, wenn du jetzt sagst, meinetwegen, die kriegen jetzt alle neun Monate ein Kind und die Kinder kriegen wiederum alle neun Monate ein Kind, kannst dir eine mathematische Formel aufstellen, wie lange es dauern würde, bis wir auf der Bevölkerung von sieben Milliarden Menschen wären. Und dann leider auch, kann man sehr gut ausrechnen. Dann ziehen wir noch Weltkriege ab irgendwie, 60 Millionen Zweiter Weltkrieg. Und ziehen wir die 75 Prozent ab, die behindert werden, weil einfach Bruder und Schwester nicht miteinander schlafen sollten. Genau, alle, die an Gluten gestorben sind, auch nochmal raus, irgendwie auch nochmal 12 Milliarden, zack, nochmal alle raus. Und dann hast du aber eine gute Zahl, dann kannst du sagen, okay, Noah war genau zu der Zeit. Das habe ich tatsächlich versucht auszurechnen und dann dachte ich mir, geil, ich habe eine Antwort, aber... Das war wieder eine Schule, es kommt eine Formel raus und man weiß nicht, ist es jetzt richtig. Genau, es kommt eine neue Formel raus. Ich weiss damit nicht einmal genau, was soll ich damit anfangen? Hä, ist gleich K-L-M, das kann ja auch nicht sein. Aber auf jeden Fall habe ich dann nochmal in der Bibel nachgeschaut und da stand tatsächlich, nachdem Noah und seine Familie angekommen sind im Neuen Land, wurden sie mit grosser Fruchtbarkeit gesegnet. Und da dachte ich mir, fuck, die sind schon nicht dumm in der Bibel, die sind nicht doof, die haben sich auf sowas vorbereitet, dass irgendwie Leute denken, die Bibel ist wasserdicht, die ist absolut wasserdicht, wirklich, hast du keine Chance, an die Bibel ranzukommen. Aber ich weiss nicht, man sollte mal vielleicht ein paar Anwälte drüber lesen lassen, ob die nicht vielleicht ein Schlupfloch finden, vielleicht hier und da, aber ich glaube, es ist wirklich ziemlich fest, da kriegst du kein, findest du kein Loch, aber finde ich geil, dass die sich gegen sowas abgesichert haben, einfach knallhart sagen, zack, einfachkeit. Glaubst du, wie viele Leute haben, glaubst du, die Bibel geschrieben?
Puh, eine Menge Ghostwriter, glaube ich.
Da waren eine Menge unterbezahlte Autoren, die irgendwie so
schreibt 20 Gags, was leint sich auf dem Wort hier.
Holy Ghostwriter. Holy Ghost.
Nice one.
Der war nicht schlecht.
Der Holy Ghostwriter? Der war nicht schlecht.
Der hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Das ist aber nett. Wirklich gut gefallen. Das ist aber nett jetzt. Wir sollten auch aufhören, unsere Witze zu feiern. Wenn sie so gut sind, also wenn mal einer um die Ecke kommt. Ja, das stimmt, der war schon sehr gut. Der war schon sehr gut. Apropos Licht, bist du fotogen? Fotos sind auch so ein Ding, entweder man kann es oder man kann es nicht. Ja, was heißt fotogen, also man lernt ja, wenn man viele Fotos von sich sieht, lernt man natürlich irgendwann, wie man gut aussieht und nicht. Und das ist eine Fähigkeit, die jeder Mensch instinktiv entwickelt und weiß, wie er gut aussieht und nicht. Und deswegen weiss ich auch schon relativ im Vorhinein, wenn ich auf Bildern scheisser aussehen werde. Und dann guckt man natürlich dumm und denkt sich, ah scheisse, und dann guckt man noch dummer aus. Letztens habe ich, ich glaube, vor ein paar Tagen ein grosses Idol von mir getroffen, und der wollte ein Selfie mit mir machen, und ich war total happy. Du hast es auch getwittert. Dann haben wir dieses Selfie gemacht, haben es uns angeschaut, und beide haben so einen kurzen Moment innegehalten, und wir sahen beide wirklich, wirklich scheiße aus. Es war so halb von unten irgendwie, Licht so halb, der Scheinwerfer hinten war so ein bisschen ... Licht! Es sah wirklich furchtbar aus. Und es gab diesen wunderschönen, kurzen telepathischen Moment des, wir beide gleichzeitig ... Er macht mal lieber noch eins so, wo wir beide genau gesehen haben, das sieht scheiße aus. Dann haben wir noch eins gemacht, sahen wesentlich besser aus und das ist auch das, was ihr im Internet betrachten könnt. Ach, das war das Gute. Ha, kleiner Gag am Rande. Nee, aber ich bin absolut nicht fotogen, aber ich finde es auch nicht schlimm. Ach, das steht mich auch nicht drüber auf. Nein, das meine ich gar nicht so. Da wurde auf diesem Pizzakarton, das sieht doch schon ganz gut aus. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Was übrigens der beste Gag ever ist. Wo ich wirklich, glaube ich, einmal im Monat, muss ich daran denken, jetzt war anscheinend, hast du irgendwo mal eine Pizzapackung gefunden,
wo ein Pizzabäcker auf abgebildet war,
der gemalt wurde, der ziemlich exakt genauso aussieht wie du und hast das als
ein Facebook-Profilbild benutzt und ich finde das so lustig.
Ich denke da, glaube ich, einmal im Monat denke ich
daran, wie lustig das ist,
dass man eine Pizzakartonpackung findet,
wo man selber als Pizzabäcker drauf ist.
Ich habe es nicht selber gefunden.
Was irgendwie so eine dämonische Voraussicht
in die dunkle Zukunft ist. Es ist echt gruselig gewesen, aber es sieht haargenau so aus. Damit könnte ein Abenteuer beginnen. Der Held wacht auf und seine Schule ist ein bisschen Versager, ist ein bisschen lisa. Wir spielen das durch, das Abenteuer spielen wir durch. Okay, morgen. Ich weiß nicht genau, ich mache ein Setting, okay, gib mir das Setting. Okay, Schlafzimmer, Stefan Titzel zu Hause, er schläft noch, Vogel zwitschern. Plötzlich Wecker. Erstmal Snooze-Taste, habe ich gedrückt. Ja, okay, gut. Okay. Stefan! Ja? Wach endlich auf, du musst in die Arbeit! Scheiße. Ich will, dass du die endlich mal ausziehst. Du bist 24 Jahre alt, du musst immer noch bei deiner Tante. Du musst jetzt endlich raus, verdient nicht mehr Geld. Exposition? Verdient endlich mehr Geld, raus jetzt oder ich komm gleich rein. Scheiße. Okay, er braucht wieder einen Job. Nee, er hat schon einen Job. Ich rede in dritten Person. Okay, er hat aber schon einen Job, er wurde gerade in der Exposition gesagt, dass er einen Job hat. So funktioniertro nicht. Du kannst nicht Dinge, die ich einleite, sofort negieren. Geh endlich zu deinem Job. Okay, ich muss einen neuen Job finden. Ich habe gerade in der Exposition nicht richtig zugehört, weil mein Handy ging. Aber ich glaube, ich habe schon einen Job. Also Stefan Titzer erhebt sich. Ich mache mich fertig und gehe raus. Man sieht einen Shot, man sieht den Spiegel, man denkt, es wäre das echte Bild, aber dann wird zurückgezoomt und er steht vor dem Spiegel, setzt sich seine Mütze auf, fährt sich nochmal durchs Haar, guckt sich selbst in die Augen mit so einem, ach, das wird ein scheiß Tag, Blick, macht die Tür auf, geht raus, man sieht ihn, er ist komplett durcheinander, Hose falsch angezogen, er stolpert über die Treppe, er geht zur Tür raus, die Mutter nochmal hinterher, Stefan, du hast seinen Rucksack vergessen, er kriegt nochmal seinen Rucksack vergessen. Seinen Turnbeutel. Seinen Turnbeutel. Wir haben die Figur etabliert. Stefan Titzel ist etabliert, man kann sich sofort in den Hinein versetzen, es geht los. Und zwar fährt Stefan Titzel, sitzt im Bus, man hört das Rattern, Stefan Titzel wird durchgeschüttelt, eine hübsche junge Dame steigt ein, schaut sich im Bus rum. Oin. Steigt ein. Steigt ein. Sie kommt aus Hamburg. Sie spielt in Hamburg.
Sie kommt aus Hamburg.
Lecker Mädchen, du.
So, steigt ein, schaut Stefan Titzel kurz an, ein kurzer Augenkontakt entsteht.
Stefan Titzel versucht sich zu einem Lächeln durchzuringen.
Das Mädchen guckt erschrocken weg, setzt sich neben einen fetten, stinkenden Typen, obwohl der Rest des Busses leer gewesen wäre.
Stefan Titzel ist weiter erklärt, die Figur formt sich langsam, er hat keinen Erfolg bei Frauen, er ist ein Versager, er ist ein Loser, aber wo führt diese Geschichte hin?
Und er steigt aus, es regnet mittlerweile, die Tür geht auf, Stefan Titzel steigt raus, steigt in eine Pfütze rein, wir sehen Close-up vor seinem Gesicht, Stefan Titzel ist am Ende, er hat einfach keine Lust mehr.
Stefan Titzel fängt an zu weinen, doch die Träne rinnt ihm die Backe runter, wir sehen ganz close auf die Träne, sie fällt herunter, fällt auf den Boden und trifft, plock, die Pfütze.
Ein Pizzakarton. Stefan Titze schaut herunter und sieht da etwas im Regen, eine ganz läpprige, glitschige Masse formt sich da und Stefan Titze denkt, ach, ich bin eh schon am Boden, egal was das jetzt ist, egal welches Abenteuer mir jetzt hier entgegengeworfen wird, Schicksal, was auch immer du für mich bereithältst, ich bin bereit, denn mir kann es nicht schlechter gehen. Stefan Titze nimmt also den Karton auf, schaut ihn sich an und er sieht sich selbst. Er sieht sich selbst auf dem Pizzakarton als Pizzabäcker und da fällt ihm ein Flashback, wir sehen so einen Rückspuleffekt, wir sehen Stefan Titzel als kleiner Junge, er wird von seiner, seine Mutter, bringt ihm einen, einen, einen, einen Teig, Stefan Titzel knete den Teig, er hat ganz viel Spaß, er breitet es auf dem Backblech auf, er schiebt es in den Backblech, man sieht von innen dem Ofen, sieht man durch die Ofentür, sieht man ihn, wie er ganz erwartungsvoll auf, auf den Teig schaut, der Teig geht auf, es ist so ein Zeichen für seine Kindheit, Pubertät, der Teig geht auf, irgendwie er sitzt da mit seiner Mutter, doch dann plötzlich, wir hören einen Autokreischen, zack, Zusammenprall, Grabstein, Mutter, Tod, Stefan Tietze steht alleine am Grab, senkt den Kopf, sein Traum vom Backen ist vorbei. Und Daniel Kühlböck sind noch Amazing Grace. Genau, und Daniel Kühlböck hat einen kleinen Cameo. In diesem Moment, in dem Stefan Tietze wieder dieses Bild vor sich hat, dieser saftige, luftige Teig, diese Tomaten, dieser Basilikum, kommt alles in ihm hoch. Die Liebe zum Backen, die Liebe zur Kunst, die Liebe, kreative Dinge erschaffen zu können, Leute damit zu erfreuen, Sachen zu backen, Freude in das Leben von anderen zu bringen, Stefan Titzer hat seine Berufung gefunden.
Stefan Titzer wird Testimonial für Domino's Pizza, weil er eine ganz schlimme Lebensmittelallergie hat und es eigentlich nicht selber backen kann. Wir spulen mal 60 Minuten vor, irgendwas passiert, Stefan Titzer hat ein Abenteuer, am Ende trifft er auch nochmal das Mädchen aus dem Bus wieder, es kommt zum großen Highlight, sie verlieben sich, ta-ta-ta, er macht seine eigene Pizzeria auf und am Ende sitzt er in einem riesigen Hochhaus, Wolkenkratzer, die wunderschöne Frau in seinem Arm und wir sehen, die Wand ist übersät mit Preisen, bester Pizzabäcker der Welt, goldene Scheiplatte. Nein, bester Pizzatestimonie. Bestes Pizzatestimonie der Welt, er hat ganz viel Geld an die Wand gehängt und die Kamera fährt über seine Wand, also wir starten von seinem Kopf aus, dann kommt eine Musik, irgendeine coole Musik, man merkt, okay, der Film ist zu Ende, die Kamera fährt nochmal über die ganze Wand, seine ganzen Erfolge, er schüttelt Hand mit Jimmy Fallon, Jimmy Kimmel, Jimmy Gator, den ganzen Jimmys der Welt, schüttelt er die Hand, wir sehen Auszeichnungen, Urlaubsbilder, er hat alles erreicht und die Kamera fährt und ganz am Ende der Wand hängt an die Wand genagelt ein alter, nasser Pizzakarton. Black! Der Film ist vorbei, Abspann. Das ist die Geschichte von Stefan Titzel im Pizzabäcker. Und falls ihr sie kaufen wollt, dann schaut mal in einem Edeka, ob ihr irgendwo noch eine Packung mit einem halbzentimeter dicken Preisschild bergt und er findet. Für 1,50 Euro könnt ihr sie bestellen bei Amazon. Einziger Kritikpunkt wäre meinerseits gewesen, dass die Erinnerung, dass man ja nicht Pizzabäcker oder Pizzabäcker-Testimonial wird aufgrund der Erinnerung, dass die Mutter gerade gestorben ist. Nein, das erklärt doch nur, warum er seinen Träumen nicht nacheifern kann, warum er den Traum in sich hat, aber bis jetzt unterdrückt hat, weil er ihn eben mit der traurigen Erinnerung an seine Mutter verbunden hat. Ich muss sagen, dass er seine Mutter eigentlich … Die Bibel ist wasserdichter, aber war okay. Das stimmt. Okay, na gut, von mir aus. Ja, Licht … Kino und Filme sind aber auch mit Licht gemacht. Ja klar, ohne ging gar nichts, wirklich. Ohne Licht wäre eigentlich die Welt total scheiße.
Ohne Licht wäre alles dunkel, vor allem. Und was ja auch interessant ist, ist, dass wenn wir reden zum Beispiel, wir auch halt andere Frequenzen absondern als zum Beispiel Farben. Und im Prinzip ist alles, was es gibt um uns herum, sind irgendwelche Frequenzen. Wellen, ja. Ist das nicht crazy? Und wir können ja zum Beispiel Handyfrequenzen schiessen durch uns durch, durchlöchern uns Tag für Tag, millionenfach, Erdstrahlung, Röntgenwellen, Gammawellen, Atomscheisse, Astrologie, die Sterne beschießen uns mit Persönlichkeit. Ja, und durch Licht, durch und durch, aber wir kriegen davon nichts mit, weil wir es nicht sehen können, weil wir dumme, idiotische Kack-Kreaturen sind, dessen Augen nur bedingte Wahrnehmungsfunktionen haben. Wenn wir das alles sehen würden, wie geil und abgefahren und psychedelisch wäre dann die ganze Welt eigentlich. Ich glaube, die Welt wäre ein Riesendog-TV. Ja genau, die ganze Welt wäre ein Dog-TV. Habe ich übrigens noch nicht gefunden, den Sender tatsächlich. Beim Setmen habe ich den Sender gefunden. Du bist hängengeblieben. Ich bin hängengeblieben, es hat mich gefesselt. Es waren drei Hunde, die haben gekäbbelt und geschlafen. Es war sehr langweilig. War es gekäbbelt? Für zehn Minuten haben die sich im Schlaf so ein bisschen getreten. So zwei Hundewelpen oder so. Weisse Hundewelpen. Gäbbelt? Da habe ich ein Wort, das ich in meinem Leben noch nie gehört habe. Gäbbelt. Was ist das denn? So leicht necken. Neck andötschen, immer so spielerisch kämpfen. Wow, das habe ich noch nie gehört. Schlecht. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst, jetzt zweifle ich gerade ein bisschen an mir selbst, dass es das Wort gar nicht gibt, aber ich vertraue mir mal kebbeln. Okay, gut. Was ist kebbeln? New words with Stephanie. Was ist kebbeln? Drei Fragezeichen. Kebbeln ist gleich zanken, itchen, streiten. Auch itchen, das ist auch gut, Worte, die man nicht kennt, mit Worten zu erklären, die man auch nicht kennt. Kebbeln ist sowas wie itchen halt. Okay, klar. Synonyme für itchen. Wer war Nietzsche? Ja, so einer wie Schopenhauer. Okay. Oh, je, je, je, du mit deinen Philosophengags. Philosophophengags funktioniert nicht. Philosophengags. Philosophic Gags can't be funny. Es gibt, es im Deutschen fehlen Worte. Tatsächlich ist mir aufgefallen, es gibt im Deutschen nicht genug Worte. Was in der Welt kannst du nicht beschreiben? Und zwar, ich mache es ganz konkret, damit auch der Zuschauer was davon hat. Ja, dann mach's konkret. Und zwar das englische Verb to mouth something, to mouth something, also etwas sagen, ohne dabei Geräusche zu erzeugen. Also mit den Lippen sprichst du das Wort, aber du sagst es nicht wirklich laut. Soufflieren? Nein, etwas ganz anderes. To mouth something. Sprechen ohne Ton? Ja, man kann es nur umschreiben, aber auch sprechen ohne Ton glaube ich nicht, dass sich da jeder wirklich was vorstellen kann. Aber to mouth ist einfach das perfekte Wort. Etwas munden. Das ist eigentlich, trifft es genau, aber gibt es im Deutschen nicht. Es ist halt einfach. Auch eine Sendung, also Showrunner, to run a show, in dem Sinne eine, ja, ich kann es nicht beschreiben, man kann es nicht sagen. Ja, ich habe mal ganz kurz im Dictionary nachgeschaut, to mouth something, etwas lautlos mit den Lippenformen, ja, cool, cooler Typ, richtig cooles Ding. Jetzt such mal nach to run something. To run? To run something. Ach stimmt, ja, to run, ne? Laufen, Rennen, betreiben, betreiben. Ja, betreiben. Naja, ist halt nicht das Richtig. Rinnen. To run a TV-Show heißt einfach die so, also die quasi ... Wusstest du, dass das Verb von geronnen rinnen heißt? Ich rinne, er rinnt, er sie es rinnt. Von geronnen.
Ich bin ein Marathon gerinnt.
Die Gags werden nicht besser.
Schon des Öfteren. Ich habe kurz eine Anekdote zu erzählen.
Ja, hau raus.
Die hat ein Kollege mir erzählt, ich werde sie so gut wiedergeben, wie ich kann. Und zwar war neulich, also alles was zählt. Es gibt diese Soap-Operas, die deutschen Serien, die deutsche Antwort auf Breaking Bad, auf Game of Thrones, sind halt Dinge wie alles was zählt, wie Anna und die Liebe und sowas. Dinge, die eigentlich unter meinem Radar laufen, aber diese Geschichte fand ich sehr interessant. Und zwar wollten die nämlich alles ein bisschen neu aufziehen, es lief nicht mehr richtig gut, Charaktere sollten ausgetauscht werden, Schauspieler sollten weg. Und wie würden es die Amerikaner machen? Die Amerikaner würden Geschichten full circle erzählen, sie würden die vielschichtigen Kreaturen, die sie erschaffen haben, würden sie sterben lassen, Situationen, die für die Figur entsprechend sinnvoll sind,
die den Zuschauer fesseln,
die Überraschungen sind. Wie machen es die Deutschen?
Das ist die geilste Geschichte,
dass das niemand mitbekommen hat.
Also du musst vorstellen, es ist halt auch nicht wie Game of Thrones
oder so, dass dauernd Leute sterben,
sondern es ist halt eine sehr liebevoll, sehr langsam,
sehr tragedy,
comedy-mässig erzählte
Haltung und dann
haben in einer Folge haben die
alle, alle, alle Schauspieler
Vielen Dank. sehr Tragedy-Comedy-mäßig erzählte Haltung. Und dann haben die in einer Folge alle, alle, alle Schauspieler in einen Bus gesteckt und haben den verunglücken lassen. Wie geil ist das? Eieiei! Stell dir vor, du guckst seit zwei Jahren diese Sendung, du liebst die Charaktere, und auf einmal gehen alle in diesen Bus und die lassen den Bus verunglücken und alle sterben. In einer Folge, von einer auf die anderen Folge sind alle Charaktere tot. Vor allem allein, dass man alle Figuren einer Serie in einem Raum hat. So die Ex-Freundin kommen, Opa, Oma, alle sind da. Was ist denn das für ein Bus? Was ist denn hier los? Stell dir mal vor, du kommst in den Bus und alle Menschen, die du kennst, sitzen in dem Bus. Und ich sage, was ist denn hier los? Und dann alle tot. Vor allem auch die Schauspieler so, weil die Schauspieler haben ja keinen Job mehr, die müssen dann auch gedacht haben, nein, mein Schauspieler will nicht in diesen Bus, also meine Rolle fährt gar nicht gerne Bus, der geht lieber zu Fuß. Genau, sie haben sich am Set gesträumt, in den Bus zu gehen, nein, ich will nicht da rein. Alle wissen schon, sowas passiert, nein, meine Figur will da nicht rein! Nein! Aber wie gross an dieser Stelle! Ich bin krank, ich kann nicht zum Dreh kommen, ich bin leider krank. Ich will nicht in diesem Dreh sein. Aber was für eine geile Story. Das ist schon gut, das ist schon wirklich filigran mit Fingerspitzengefühl gelöst, so muss es sein. Das ist schon echt lustig. So sind wir die Deutschen, die lustigen, die lustigen, sensiblen Typen, die einfach gut wissen können, wie sie mit so einer Sache angeht. Und die auch einfach gut Geschichten erzählen können, so ein bisschen Schruvelpetermäßig, so ein kleines, als Kinderbuch getarnte Geschichten. Das hat massiv eskaliert gegen Ende einfach. Und irgendwann werden Finger abgeschnitten, weil das so sein muss. Das hat sie echt übertragen. Ja. Eine liebevoll erzählte Geschichte über Affären, aber auch nicht wirklich schlimme Sachen, über Liebschaften, über hier eine Freundschaft, da eine Freundschaft, da geht mal ein bisschen was kaputt, dann kommt alles wieder zusammen, aber sterben alle! Tod! Alle Charaktere sterben grausam tot und auch nicht irgendwie an alter Schwäche, sondern sie sterben an einem grausamen Busunfall. Wow. Ja, das könnte uns auch passieren im Podcast-Ufo, wir schweben ja noch so leicht über den Dingen in unserem kleinen Ufo, aber auch wir können mal abstürzen. Wie geil das wäre, wenn ich einen Zwillingsbruder hätte, der genauso klingt wie ich. Wie gut es wäre, wenn ich einen Zwillingsbruder hätte, der genauso klingt wie ich, und du würdest nie merken, mit wem du gerade sprichst, und du wunderst dich, warum du Geschichten zweimal erzählen kannst und beide Male lache ich genauso doll wie beim ersten Mal.
Ey, das wäre ideal.
Wie lustig wäre das?
Also für mich wäre es perfekt, wenn alle Leute, die ich kennen,
mindestens so zwei, drei Zwillinge haben und ich alle Storys einfach immer wieder erklären kann.
Und die Leute lachen sich gar nicht mehr.
Die habe ich ja schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
aber die Leute lieben die einfach diese Story.
Die lieben diese Shakespeare-Anekdote, diese messerscharfe Observation.
Die können nicht genug davon bekommen.
Ich glaube, also zum Abschluss der Folge, glaube ich,
ich habe noch eine, mir ist das passiert überhaupt,
haue ich jetzt auch noch mal raus.
Und jetzt Besser scharfe Observation. Die können nicht genug davon bekommen. Ich glaube, also zum Abschluss der Folge, glaube ich, ich habe noch eine, ich habe mir, was passiert überhaupt, haue ich jetzt auch noch mal raus. Und zwar habe ich mir gedacht, ich werde dich jäh unterbrechen mit süffisanten Kommentaren. Und zwar Shakespeare hat ja über 1200 neue Worte in die englische Sprache eingeführt. Es werden auch immer mehr. Es werden immer mehr. Das ist auch geil, wenn man eine Geschichte erzählt von sich selber, irgendwie eine lustige Geschichte und man merkt nicht, dass man die noch mal erzählt und dem schon mal erzählt hat, aber die Daten verändern sich immer weiter. Ja, genau. Man hat immer mehr geschafft, man war immer besser als in der ersten Geschichte. Und wie geil, wie entlarvend das auch ist. Ja, natürlich, man schätzt das ja alles so halb lang. Am Anfang waren es 200 Wörter, mittlerweile hat es tatsächlich mit 1200, in ein paar Jahren hat er Millionen Wörter erfunden. Wo landen wir denn da? Und das entlarvt dich auch als unwissenden Menschen. Aber was ich mir denke, also wenn du so ein neues Wort entwickelst, willst du zum Beispiel mit Kemlan oder Kepplan oder was auch immer und du führst dieses Stück Uhr auf, also du führst das Theaterstück, in dem dieses Wort benutzt, wird das allererste Mal auf, zum Beispiel so eine Formulierung wie I'm in a pickle, ja, ich bin in Gefahr, in einer schlechten Situation, und der Schauspieler sagt das das allererste Mal auf der Bühne, dann weiss doch auch keine Sau, was damit gemeint ist, und der Schauspieler sagt dann Oh my God, I'm in a pickle, a huge giant eating slime monster, und alle so, sorry, in a what, what was that, so. Also, finde ich, ist eine relativ messerscharfe beobachtete Situation, auch übertragen auf ein Beispiel, das irgendwie humoristisch rübergebracht wurde. Die Wortwahl war okay vom Redefluss jetzt her, so mittelmässig, aber alles in allem. Klar, die Pointe hat nicht gesessen, aber ich glaube, im Endeffekt kann man da sagen, das war eine absolut solide 3 von 10. Da kann man nicht viel falsch machen und deswegen finde ich jetzt, ja, war es das für mich. Ich habe nichts mehr zu sagen. Stefan Titzel, schön, dass du da warst. Vielen Dank für diese fantastische Folge. Tatsächlich nächste Folge werden wir wieder gemeinsam im Tonstudio aufnehmen, wir sind wieder zusammen. Nein, das ist keine gute Idee. Es wird wieder eine schlechte Idee, wahrscheinlich werden wir es wieder in Booster holen. Mal gucken. Du bist heute echt in so einer Monologartigen Phase, du bist heute sehr mächtig gewesen, du bist ein mächtiger Co-Moderator. Ich finde, du hast super Sachen gehabt, du hast die Physiker aufgezählt, du hast uns erklärt, was Licht ist, was ich tatsächlich wirklich ernst gemeint sehr beeindruckend fand, weil das wirklich fundiert klang. Ich finde, du hast wirklich gute Sachen gebracht, du hast an der Anmoderation viel gemacht, du hattest den ersten Redeteil, das ist sowieso nur das, worauf die Leute antworten. Und jetzt am Ende ist es ja nicht so, als würde ich nur die ganze Zeit irgendeine Scheisse erzählen und du gar nichts mehr sagen und ich einfach abmoderiere und ihr überhaupt nicht die Chance zu geben.
Von daher würde ich sagen, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Falls ihr Themenvorschläge habt, schickt sie uns einfach per Facebook, per Mail, per Twitter, egal was.
Twittert fleissig mit Hashtag Das Podcast UFO und ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche. Bis dann, macht's gut, tschüss, das Podcast im Vortil.